38 تهمه جنائيه يواجهها ترامب في ثاني
لائحه اتهام ضده واولي لائحه اتهام
فيدراليه ضد رئيس سابق في تاريخ امريكا
فما هي هذه التهم وهل ستؤثر على ترشحه
للرئاسه اولا ابرز هذه التهم واخطرها وفقا
لمحللين هي الاحتفاظ بوثائق سريه داخل
صناديق بشكل غير مصرح به والتامر لعرقله
العداله بعد مغادرته البيت الابيض في عام
2021 اضافه الى الاحتفاظ بسجلات تتضمن
اسرارا نوويه لدوله اجنبيه تضر بالامن
القومي الامريكي
لائحه الاتهام الجديده التي اعلنتها وزاره
العدل تاتي بعدما صادر محققون قبل عام
تقريبا 30 صندوقا من منتجع ترامب في
فلوريدا بعض هذه الصناديق يحتوي على اوراق
حساسه جدا تتعلق بالصيني وايران لكن قبل
ان تتم مصادره هذه الصناديق كانت ترامب
وافق في يناير من العام 2022 على اعاده 15
صندوقا تحتوي على نحو 200 وثيقه سريه
محاموه اكدوا حينها في رساله عدم وجود اي
اوراق اخرى الا ان الشرطه الفيدراليه وبعد
فحص ما تسلمته قدرت ان ترامب لم يعد كل
شيء وانه ما زال يحتفظ بالكثير من الوثائق
لذا اقتحمت منزله وصدرت بقيتها الرئيس
السابق دافع حينها عن احتفاضه بالوثائق
مشيرا الى انه رفع السريه عنها عندما كان
رئيسا لكنه في الوقت ذاته لم يقدم دليلا
لعلمكم فقط القانون في امريكا يلزم جميع
رؤساء البلاد بارسال خطاباتهم ورسائل
البريد الالكتروني ووثائق العمل الاخرى
الى الارشيف الوطني
ويحضر على اي شخص الاحتفاظ بوثائق سريه في
اماكن غير مصرح بها وغير مؤمنه طيب ما
تعليق ترامب على ما يحدث الان الرئيس
السابق الذي تم استدعائه للمثول امام
محكمه الاتحاديه في ميامي في فلوريدا بعد
ظهر يوم الثلاثاء الثالثه عشر من يونيو
الجاري خرج بفيديو الى جماهيره مؤكدا لهم
انه بريء من جميع التهم
ما حدث مع ترامب اليوم تزامنا ايضا مع
اعلاني محاميين من فريق دفعه في قضيه
اساءه التعامل مع الوثائق السريه تقديم
استقالتيهما لاسباب مجهوله لكن ماذا علق
بايدن الذي يتهمه ترامب بالمناسبه بالفساد
وبتلفيق التهامي له
في النهايه قد يكون السؤال الابرز حاليا
هل يمكن ان يتاثر ترشح ترامب بما يحدث معه
الان خبراء قانونيون في الولايات المتحده
يقولون ان توجيه الاتهام رسميا الى اي شخص
وحتى صدور حكم عليه الارتكابه جنحه او
جريمه لا يمنعه من ان يترشح او ينتخب او
يشغل منصبا رسميا في المقابل يرى اخرون ان
هذه الاتهامات قد تضعف من شعبيه ترامب
المرشح الابرز لدى الحزب الجمهوري في
السباق الرئاسي وانتم ما رايكم